okay I'm here to tell you that there is
a really important battle going on for
the New World Order but I'm not talking
about the shadowy totalitarian
conspiracy theory stuff that we often
hear so much about so I'm going to set
this up for you if you've not heard of
these NWO New World Order conspiracies
I actually congratulate you you're
probably living a great life away from
the toxicity of this nonsense but I'll
explain to you the way that these
theories tend to go it's some version of
the New World Order is a clandestine
effort by powerful shadowy players of
the world to create a totalitarian world
government to rule over everybody now
that that's like the top line there are
endless versions of this sometimes they
involve freemasons could be the
Illuminati of course sometimes it's the
Jews that are involved sometimes it's
more of like a new-age type of thing
there is often a mass surveillance sort
of dystopian elements sometimes it's
framed more as an impending coup there
are others who are more nuanced than
they say gradualism is going to be the
way in which this new world order is
implemented it's not going to be all at
once it'll be a little erosion of civil
liberties here and erosion of the
sovereignty of countries a little bit
there there are sort of population
control centric versions sometimes
aliens and UFOs figure into it there can
be religious connections that involve
Bible prophecy or the rapture or the
apocalypse you get the idea but the
general gist of it is a conspiracy for a
shadowy world government to take over in
a totalitarian way control of all people
living on earth now all of that stuff is
nonsense but there actually is a battle
for what I think can accurately be
called a new world order in the sense of
a geopolitical realignment new world
order among the great powers and right
now this is a battle being fought
involving the United States and China
and Russia I encourage you to read more
international relations to get more of a
grasp on this topic and I suggest to you
that the the if if you do that you are
very quickly going to realize that a lot
of the stuff Trump is doing with Russia
and China is important for reasons that
are totally separate from the cartoonish
media stories okay when we talk about
Trump screwing up trade and tariffs with
China or when we talk about Trump
seemingly sort of subservient
subservient relationship to Vladimir
Putin it's not about Republicans versus
Democrats it's not about progressive
versus conservative if you understand
geopolitics and international relations
you recognize that this is a key moment
because these relationships us-china US
Russia and China Russia are inevitably
going to set the stage for the next
significant period of time in terms of
how the sort of major powers will relate
to each other into the rest of the world
the rising circumstances are that on one
hand Donald Trump is increasingly
hostile with China and he's making
economic blunders with China and Chinese
economic policy on the other hand Trump
is too dumb to see how while Putin is
manipulating him he's doing it in a very
particular way that is useful in ways
Trump can't even conceive of to Russia
which we'll get to and meanwhile and
this is like the third part of the
triangle Russia and China are building a
relationship that could be significantly
negative for the US now let me issue a
sort of soft disclaimer you might hear
me talking about this and say David you
know we should just get along with
everybody you're sounding like an
economic nationalist about the US has to
win and that's just the wrong approach
it's not about that whether or not
you're an economic nationalist or a
so-called pro US person to use like a
really coarse term there's a case to be
made that it's not just about what's
good for American power but just about
what's good for simple everyday
Americans who live in the United States
and I happen to be one of those people
so I'll give you some data points about
how this could start to shake out which
wouldn't be good for just average
Americans look at Trump China trade
relations Trump tariffs China
you will now have years of these tariffs
at a minimum does China suffer very
little they deal with other countries
other countries choose to deal more with
China than with American companies
because it's cheaper this is bad for
American businesses as far as our
citizens and companies are concerned the
tariffs on China are paid by American
companies who have to pay more to buy
stuff from China stuff that we need we
pay more as American consumers for
products that involve Chinese raw
materials or Chinese production would we
love to be doing business more with our
own companies and american-made goods
sure of course we would but most of our
economy can't take it stagnant wages
people are living paycheck to paycheck
so our tariffs on China alienate us from
them without really hurting them but
they make more countries turn to China
instead of us in terms of doing business
that's bad for the United States
meanwhile Trump thinks he's making nice
with Putin it's so nice to get along but
Putin's much smarter than Trump and he's
using Trump being enamored with them to
Russia's advantage while swooping in and
rekindling China Russia relationships
hugely also in ways that aren't great
for the United States an example China
giving Russian energy companies credits
Russia giving China access to their
energy deposits China's army getting
access to Russian military technology
they're doing joint training they're
coordinating diplomatically in the
middle of that is North Korea as a
nation sort of caught in the middle of
the desires of Russia and China and the
more Russia and China get along the more
difficult it will be for the United
States to have leverage there and
meanwhile as I've mentioned before on
climate change one of the foremost
issues of our time we have the world
just ignoring the United States because
Trump has said climate change is a hoax
created by the Chinese and that's a
disaster so let me be super clear my
analysis is not from a neoliberal
perspective we need I'm not saying we
need to prop up the United States at the
expense of everybody else it's an
analysis of a situation that's simply
too difficult and complex
for Donald Trump to handle no matter
what your view is of what should be
happening in each of these relationships
the red alert is that we have someone
completely unqualified overseeing this
now we have a borderline criminal real
estate dude who's rich because his dad
was rich in charge when no matter what
your politics are we should have someone
involved in these negotiations with
knowledge and capacity at what is an
extraordinarily important time that's
the real New World Order battle that's
going on it's not about Freemasons and
Jews in the Illuminati and unfortunately
we have one of the worst possible people
managing it make sure you follow the
David Pakman show on Instagram we'll
have a poll question related to this
story at david pakman show on instagram
and while you're there follow me as well
i'm at david pakman on instagram